Це - Мартін Патцельт, депутат Бундестагу з 2013 року,
колишній бургомістр Франкфурта-на-Одері.
А це - член виборчої команди депутата,
український студент Олексій Кисляк.
Сьогодні у них непросте завдання –
проїхати кілька десятків кілометрів округом в землі Бранденбург
на велосипедах, утім ще складніше - вербувати виборців.
Олексій народився в Києві та навчався в КПІ.
Згодом отримав стипендію для навчання у німецькій Єні,
а потім у Франкфурті-на-Одері.
Університет розташований в окрузі Мартіна Патцельта.
З їхнього знайомства почалась робота юнака у Бундестазі.
Як мені здається, українці більш працьовиті і цілеспрямовані.
І завдяки цьому можна теж багато досягнути.
Це найсхідніша Східна Німеччина,
ще кілометрів 30 – і кордон з Польщею.
Частина електорату вважає, що через відсутність кордонів
поляки крадуть техніку, а з півдня наступають біженці
з країн Близького Сходу та Африки.
Виборці категорично не йдуть на контакт
з представниками партії Анґели Меркель.
Справу Олексію ускладнює й український акцент.
Люди теж питають: ти ж сам не німець,
а хочеш нас переконувати,
щоб Німеччина приймала біженців.
А я пояснюю, що найголовніше - це бажання тих людей,
які приїжджають сюди, інтегруватися.
Конкуренти Патцельта в окрузі – крайні ліві та крайні праві.
І ті, і інші - значно м‘якші до Росії,
аніж він та німецький уряд.
Найвідоміший опонент - Александер Ґауланд,
лідер "Альтернативи для Німеччини", який хоче
остаточно визнати Крим російським і зняти санкції з Кремля.
Патцельт каже, українське питання відіграє
важливу роль на цих виборах у ФРН.
Це є внутрішньополітичною темою лише в тому смислі,
що в нас існує ембарго щодо Росії.
Якраз в моєму окрузі є рішучо налаштовані сили
послабити це ембарго.
Але я вважаю, ХДС і СДПН в цьому питанні
дуже принципові й наполегливі -  права людини
ми ставимо вище за економічні зиски.
Коли йдеться про питання України, Олексій
роз'яснює депутату нюанси або ж готує тези для виступів.
Українець вважає, що ХДС найбільше відстоює і
підтримує Україну серед німецьких партій.
ХДС має найчіткішу позицію
Але коли це коаліція і треба ще
з партнером по коаліції домовитись
про важливі питання – це інколи непросто.
Наприклад, Соціал-демократична партія має набагато
слабкішу та привітливішу позицію щодо Росії ніж ХДС.
Загалом, відзначає Олексій, у Німеччині виборча кампанія
не така інтенсивна, як буває в Україні.
Немає білбордів на кожному кроці,
що засмічують простір, та багатомісячного очікування,
коли ж вони закінчаться.
Як і чотири роки тому, Патцельт хоче агітувати
«від дверей до дверей» , тобто
в безпосередньому спілкуванні з виборцями.
Однак громадяни відвертаються від агітаторів.
Та через деякий час партійна колона велосипедистів
знаходить охочого співрозмовника.
Він прибічник крайньо правої АфД.
В розмові, що триває півгодини,
переконати чоловіка так і не вдається.
- Ми обираємо політиків, які мають представляти народ.
- Добре.
-І дотримуватись законів.
- І я маю права як німецький громадянин.
- А їх проігнорували.
– Які права проігнорували?
– Я ж кажу. Я ж не тримаю всю Конституцію в голові.
– То які права проігнорували? Не можна ж просто так казати.
Увечері Олексій планує для свого шефа
наступний день велотуру.
Куди саме їхати, де і як саме агітувати.
Він не проти у майбутньому серйозно
зайнятися політичною діяльністю.
І місяць тому зробив для цього перший крок –
вступив до ХДС.
Політичні амбіції 24-річному юнаку важливі,
аби допомогти Україні використати свій,
на його думку, величезний потенціал.